bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du aux nordistes au nord à saillé
confirmer la date de sortie de son
smartphone en france il a été présenté
on l'a vu il ya pas très longtemps en
chine
ça y est yves arrivée en france hormis
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant parce que
en réalité en terme de prix dispositions
extrêmement bien par rapport à un énorme
ouf il est un peu moins cher mais sans
valve détails et on y va
[Musique]
le ordis c'est effectivement un produit
en plus dans la gamme de honor l'année
dernière il ya eu au nord 9 le haut
review dit ce qui est arrivé en début
d'année puis pas d'autre produit le set
je ne sais plus colonna fait quelques
appels numérotation une numérotation qui
devient un petit peu plus compliqué chez
au nord alors là effectivement j'en ai
déjà parlé à quelques temps le aux
nordistes étaient présentés en chine et
à quelques semaines
là j'ai eu l'occasion d'en discuter dans
une précédente vidéo vous pouvez aller
boire et l'ajustement bon point d'une
fiche technique c'est toujours la même
chose le temps d'essayer de comprendre
un peu ce qu'il ya derrière tout ça la
stratégie marketing de honor voir
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils nous sortent ce
produit là est ce qu'il est intéressant
par rapport aux autres produits de la
gamme de au nord on va aussi voir du
côté de chez huawei ce qui est
intéressant et puis essayer de
comprendre un peu des mails et des mets
un peu la stratégie derrière tout ça et
savoir au final est-ce que ceux aux
nordistes vaut le coup oui ou non
alors on va regarder déjà d'un point de
vue technique j'ai bien évidemment peu
tassés comme d'habitude on va refaire un
petit tour on a une encoche en haut on
voit effectivement que c'est encore plus
en plus de succès y compris pour les
smartphones du côté d'android
vous avez en bas une bande noire qui est
quand même assez large malgré tout on
est sur un smartphone qui met pas
forcément trop trop cher donc on pouvait
pas avoir un truc borderless paca le
design j'irai en tout cas complètement
complètement dingue complètement
révolutionnaire mais néanmoins j'ai
parfaitement bien la faire le dos se
tient plutôt bien il ne sent pas bon on
va pas non plus lui demander la lune
il est pas mal il est plutôt sexy et on
retrouve vraiment dans les standards
actuels pour des produits je dirais
milieu de gamme au point de vue de
l'écran vous avez un écran 5,84 pouces
format 18 9e cdu 2280 par 1080 pixels
c'est du f hd + 416 ppp c'est une date
ni ps et un écran lcd pour ça c'est
plutôt pas mal côté luminosité contraste
sarah parfaitement la faire vous serez
pas déçus de ce côté là ensuite au
niveau de la puissance vous avez quand
même un kirin 970 cadencé à 2,36
gigahertz ça fonctionne bien
point de vue intelligence artificielle
point de vue calcul ça marche très très
bien 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
leur fait vraiment attention parce que
ces 64 giga de stockage non extensible
contrairement à nos revues 10 qui est
extensible à l'honneur dix ne l'est pas
pour pas se planter vous avez aussi la
possibilité de l'acquérir en 128 g
y'a de stockage beaucoup trop quand même
50 euros de plus mais sale tarifs on
verra après alors côté photo vidéo c'est
plutôt pas mal
vous avez à l'arrière un double module
photo 1 de 16 mégapixels couleurs et un
20 mégapixels boulodrome un grand
classique chez au nord de couple et de
la couleur à un monochrome et à l'avant
vous avez un 24 mégapixels vous pouvez
filmer en 4k attention à la
stabilisation
c'est pas le point fort de au nord si
vous cherchez un truc stabiliser vous
passez votre chemin
côté os on tourne sous android 18.1 oreo
vous avez la surcouche emotion ui le
bluetooth 4 points 2 c'est pas de
bluetooth 5.0 mais bon ça fera la faire
vous pouvez mettre deux cartes sim
directement si vous êtes frontaliers que
vous avez une carte d'un pays de l'aude
que vous voyagez beaucoup vous avez
aussi des besoins du double carte sim à
usage professionnel
ça fera parfaitement la sphère la
recharge c'est de l'usb type c'est la
batterie sous 3400 millions terreur vous
décevra pas ça fonctionne plutôt bien et
niveau dimensions va être très précis
attention c'est un appareil qui fait 149
6 cm 71,2 cm et 7,7 mm tout ça pour un
poids que je n'ai pas noté
donc on va passer le pouvoir il est
disponible en quatre couleurs le bleu le
noir le gris est levée
alors côté tarifs c'est là que ça
devient intéressant parce que le honor
9d quand même supérieur en termes de
tarifs à 400 euros là ils ont vraiment
fait un effort pour dire et draguer tout
cette cible toute cette clientèle qui
veut des smartphones de bonne qualité et
pas cher on est à un tarif je vous dis
en dessous des 400 euros c'est vraiment
sous les 400 euros à 399,90 senti donc
là très clairement on est à 10 centimes
près en dessous des 400 euros pour le
modèle en 64 gigas si vous le voulez en
128 giga faudra rajouter 50 or plus on
est très précisément à 449 euros à 8 90
centimes on voit qu'en matériel qui est
vraiment très agressif pour aller
concurrencer tous les smartphones
chinois vous avez le asus le iphone 5
quel enseignant pas très longtemps la
chienlit qui se positionne du côté de la
corée on à samsung est aussi super
agressifs notamment avec son nouveau
galaxy à six qui va débarquer très
prochainement en france
et l'idée effectivement c'est d'avoir
une gamme toujours plus complète en gros
si on regarde bien du côté de chez au
nord quand je les fais un petit un petit
récap pour voir ce qu'on peut trouver
sur le site de north et les tarifs 1
vraiment officiel au nord vous avez des
produits qui sont d'entrée de gamme je
dirais pas trop cher
le sis acquis à 169 euros le 6 et à 179
euros le 7 c'est à 179 d'ailleurs ce
qu'ils arrêtent avec nice et
numérotation les chiffres et lettres un
petit peu pénible chez eux
le 9 lite 229 le neuf du cou qui est
passé à 329 avec 90 le cetic 269 et le
view 10 le haut de gamme avec
l'intelligence artificielle qui était
annoncé en fin d'année dernière qui est
sorti en début d'année à 499 euros alors
au final mais ça vaut le coup est-ce
qu'il faut acheter ce nouveau aux
nordistes
si vous avez un aux normes 9 est ce que
ça vaut le coup si vous avez un huit
pros est ce que ça vaut le coup si vous
avez un vieux disque ça vaut le coup
alors moi très clairement si vous avez
un viol disent pas changer ça vaut pas
le coup est normalement très très peu
d'intérêt si vous avez en or 9
pourquoi pas ça change pas grand chose
mais quand même si l'air vraiment
similaires en termes de en termes de
produits pour moi c'est un produit qui
est pas mal qui est vraiment pas mal
pour le budget ça vaut le coup il est un
tout petit peu plus cher que le webp 20
light par contre il a carrément une
fiche technique est très similaire à
celle du pévèle ep20 qui coûte quand
même beaucoup plus cher on est aux
alentours des 650 euros
donc c'est vraiment un produit qui se
positionne entre le p 20 et le paiement
à l'acte mais pour voir qu'un pépin
light coûtent quand même 370 euros etc
là vous êtes à 399 euros
si vous hésitez entre les deux il faut
très clairement aller sur le au nordiste
maintenance qui vous hésitez entre le
view 10 et le dise pour moi pour aller
sur le bio 10 c'est quand même un
produit qui va être plus sympa plus
séduisant et avec lequel vous pourrez
faire comme un peu plus de choses à
savoir quand même que la différence avec
le bénin light ces deux processeurs là
vous avez enquéri 1970 sur un pv lite
vous avez inquiries 159 un peu moins de
puissance moins de calculs pour voir
quelle différence de 20 euros pas
forcément hyper hyper sexy dont la très
clairement on voit que honor va
travailler toujours plus les personnes
qui veulent acheter des smartphones
d'entrée de gamme des smartphones moyen
de gamme et milieu de gamme la pas trop
cher détail toujours attractif pour ce
passionné par rapport à la concurrence
alors est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter je
dirais qu'il faut surtout vous voir déjà
si d'une le design vous plaît 6 2 la
marque au nord vous plaît puis au final
est-ce que ça rentre dans le moule du
oui ou non
voilà c'est un peu la question moi je
trouve que c'est un produit que l'autre
est sur le papier est plutôt pas mal
on verra tout ça bien évidemment très en
détail dans les phases de test parce
qu'on va et explique marc et allez ça
ensemble
donc restez connectés abonnez-vous
d'ailleurs dit non vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous trouvez sur le
papier en tout cas que au nordiste est
cool
est-ce qu'il vous
est-ce qu'il vous séduit vous marquez
tout ça en commentaire bien évidemment
comme d'hab on reste connectés il ya
plein de choses qui vont venir à
l'avenir justement va parler de plein de
nouveaux produits qui arrivent là en ce
mois de mai il ya plein de produits qui
fleurit de tous les côtés c'est comme
des fleurs au printemps donc on va
rester connectés en profiter comme d'hab
et a blessé des jolies plumes acte sans
commentaire il y en aura très bientôt
soyez sages ciao
[Musique]